Percy the stories I have told you about
great Gods and
Monsters they are real Walker you're
getting my my first two questions here
about the audition process cuz I was
reading that uh Rick was really Blown
Away by your tape so what were your top
priorities when making them the things
you wanted to do to make sure you set
yourself apart from everyone else
auditioning for the role I think his
sense of humor kind of came naturally to
me because I feel like we have a very
similar sense of humor it was a very
long audition process um I auditioned
back in January 2021 when I was filming
the Adam project and then I got pinned
in like February and I hear back from
them all the way until like August or
September or something and then I did
like two call backs and then in the next
January Rick called me and told me I got
the part A Long audition process is
always a good sign exactly all right I'm
putting you on the spot with this second
audition question because I was reading
that after you got the part you were
able to do chemistry reads with the
actors testing for Annabeth and Grover
so I want to know with these two when
you met them for the first time what
struck you about them that maybe made
you think like yes these are the perfect
fits for these roles with Le is
automatic um I know she's going to be
Annabeth uh she's amazing thank you Aran
on the other hand uh I really have to
prove myself then he he I don't think he
ever did prove himself oh okay this is
the first time I'm hearing it this so
yeah no yeah I mean it was I didn't know
you felt like that he really tried
that's that's the most important part he
tried you saved the drama for the Press
day very appropriate uh Aran was amazing
of course everyone that audition was
amazing but um I think I think they
picked right he's
lying I'm going to agree with what he
just said your chemistry is on point
question for all three of you now a big
question two-parter what is something
about the version of your character
that's in the book that you really
wanted to hold tight to and bring to
screen here but then I also want to know
something that you decided to bring the
role to make this version of the
character uniquely your own I feel like
at the beginning at least uh Percy's not
that cool yet he's still kind of a kid
and I feel like it came very natural to
me yeah um yeah there was no acting
involved for noting he didn't have to
like tone down his coolness at all fair
if you're if you're too cool you're
probably
boring exactly or at least that's what
I've always told
myself yeah I've I've told myself that a
couple times but um I feel like it's
important to remember that they're still
kids and um I feel like we kind of
showed that well in the show that
they're you know they're 12-year-olds
and he's 24 but acts like a 12-year-old
well you know on that uh Grover is 24
you know he he kind of behaves like a
12-year-old but he has that he has the
experience and and the wisdom that might
come with you know having lived for 24
years and that's something that you know
it's easy to forget looking at Grover
that by the end of the books he's like
um but yeah it's something that I really
wanted to to I guess kind of put at the
Forefront that he is kind of he knows
how to work his way around the gods he
understands this world very very well
and um yeah I was glad that I kind of
got to work on that with Andrew our
acting coach from the book I wanted to
bring out her strongness and her her
independence and her actual like her dry
humor actually you know like um like I
wanted to bring that out cuz there's a
lot of scenes in here where Percy is
like for example and Capture the Flag
when he tripped over the uh tree and
then I'm just staring at him like okay
completely unscripted
yeah completely from myself I wanted to
bring in a side of s it if that makes
sense like a softness to her I can feel
that I could definitely feel that combo
there all right I have to ask all three
of you about working with Rick because
he was heavily involved in this version
of uh the book going to screen this time
around so can you each maybe pinpoint
something that he did for you whether it
was a tip or some extra Insight he gave
you that made all the difference and now
we can see it on screen in the finished
product he told us cuz you know like
obviously what people say online and
stuff you know um there positive and
negative but he told us like you know to
always stay positive and to remember
that as a reminder that he picked us not
like you know like not just some random
person just said I want these two you
know Mr Rick the author the Creator the
the starter of all of this picked us to
play these characters so that's like
something in the back of our head like
to think like no matter what any of
these people say like the person who
made this picked us so like if he thinks
that we're gonna be great for This Then
I then we definitely know that this is
gonna be great so we took that and put
it into these scenes and I feel like
it's going to be great when it comes out
yeah getting to talk with Rick was I
mean invaluable this is his you know his
passion project it's his you know kind
of child he's been working on it for
almost two decades now and getting to
talk with him about like Grover it's
hard to it's easy to forget that he's
mediator for a reason and it's cuz he's
very empathetic as our coach would say
he's a sematic listener um he he's very
like tuned into to everyone's emotions
he he can kind of see through people in
a sense I'm not sure if that's the right
like phrase for it but he definitely can
tell if there's something that's being
hidden or something someone's not quite
honest and I think talking to Rick it it
was nice to kind of discuss that and
also bring that up to the to to the
Forefront all right Walker what you got
for us I've been trying to think of so I
think they summed it up Rick's the best
he that's all I can say he's the best
he's a special one that created
something a lot of people out there
dedication in the new book yeah that was
that was I can't believe anybody would
do that that is I know every time we
walk by or every time I walk by a
chalice of the Gods I always like to
open it up and look at the dedication
like the coolest thing ever yeah I love
that so much all right so having Rick be
there for you and supporting you is very
important but it's also very important
to have a supportive scene partner so
can you each name a Time on set when a
scene partner was just the person you
needed to be where they helped you
access something in your own character
that you might not have been able to
reach without them well I don't think I
really had that a lot um especially with
my main cast um I don't know just
something like I have a full sense of
your sense of humor
right um no everyone especially like the
co-stars and the guest stars were so
good getting to work with with like Adam
I I got to do a one-on-one with him in a
cafe it was so some I've I don't think
I've ever learned more from someone than
I did with him in that one-on-one scene
he was so good and he was such a
professional about it about every little
like slip up that happened he had such
like a Grace about it and I don't know
it was incredible like every moment of
that scene for that scene when you and
Luke were fighting where I was actually
there but couldn't see me cuz I have my
hat definitely in that scene and stuff
after I seen all that stuff happened and
I take the hat off and things like I was
just like I was like how dare you like
betray us like this and stuff and I felt
like I reached a certain point to where
cuz that's when Luke like seeing Percy
on the ground and stuff like you know
like suffering and things really and
then um and then I'm seeing Luke
standing there the person who was my
best friend my brother just betraying
all of us really and stuff and I thought
I could be so close to him when I see
him right there there in front of my
eyes just like be this whole different
person that I thought I would never see
in life well I mean just with the the
three of us it's like with with like
Leah in gen like Leah specifically it's
like she really gives us stuff to work
off of which is really great like just
actor wise and um I just get nothing
over here I get nothing from him um well
I don't have much to work with Okay he
doesn't have much to offer in general
interesting you say that no both it's
it's it's really great to have like
actors that really give you stuff to
work off of and I think almost every
co-star on the show we've had has done
that especially Virginia oh yeah
especially Virginia and Adam and Adam we
learned so much from them though yeah so
much there's no place for me
here you still don't get where you fit
into all this first question is a big
one can you each pinpoint something in
the source material that was especially
important to uphold in the show but then
I also want to know know something that
you had to evolve or change to suit the
new medium I think the thing that felt
um to me and I think um to Rick like it
was most important really lives in every
moment it's it's it's the voice I think
in in his mind it's what the story is
more than the monsters more than the
adventure it's the tone and um and I
think the the more time I spent with the
story the more it really does start to
feel like
um the plot's important and there's a
lot of things that that are that are
critical to to being a part of this show
um if you wanted to feel like it's
capturing the the full sense of the
journey but if any part of it fails to
live in the right with the right sense
of humor and the right of reverence and
and the right a sense of charm it all
falls apart and so I I think that was
that was the big test was um there's
lots of different things you can do with
the story as long as it feels like it
could have been in those books for that
reason and I think it was also the you
know the Greek mythology of it all is
like the amount of creatures that we
needed to show and honor from from the
books is how do you just make it
visually our own because these are
iconic things that people have seen so
many variations of for thousands of
years and how do you how do you find
very specific things that this could
only be on Percy Jackson or this could
only be something that is just so unique
and we had to find that thing with each
one of them um and that was a real tall
order and a trick to to figure that out
at this at this high level can you give
us an example of one of those the
minitar we we talk about a lot because
it was you know everyone has seen it
kind of like just man's body with a bull
head and we wanted it to also we were
like what if he's also on all fours what
if at first he's on all fours and that
makes him more powerful faster can come
at us in that way like a bull and then
all of a sudden you see a transformation
where he now stands up on two legs and
it's like oh this isn't this isn't this
isn't your everyday book I I dug it
quite a bit all right I have to ask
about uh working with Rick here every
adaptation process is different so can
you tell me a little bit about why it
was important for this show to have him
so heavily involved it's not just a
story that's super personal for him and
for his family although it is um I think
the relation ship between this fan base
and Rick and Becky is um unusual and
special and I think the the the
awareness that this story was going to
have to change a little bit to migrate
from one medium to another TR trying to
be aware of that and then think about
what it would be like to try to um
deliver that to an audience without
Rick's blessing and without Rick's
guidance and without his um his voice in
it um I don't know why you would even
try
um and so the the constant process of
being able to look to him and say um is
this right are we too far field or is
this something that's just interesting
um and and to have both his openness um
to to having those conversations and his
honesty about saying um that in it or um
that's really cool I hadn't thought of
that um was great I'll ask for an
example of that as well is there a
particular thing we can see in the show
where you had to ask him is this right
and either he put you on a better path
or confirmed you nailed it there are
Gods who do not appear in the context in
which they appear in the book but they
do in the show in the show there are
really good reasons I think why they're
there both for story for Percy's
experience for the the world we're
building but it's departure and um there
were a couple of times where um you just
got the sense it isn't time for that yet
and there were a couple of times when
you pitch it and you're a little nervous
because it's a big change and um and you
just watch him smile and feel like
that's really cool if I was a fan of
this I would really like to see that
happen and um and it it was critical I
think the the ability to have those
conversations in that way was critical
but he he also got the chance to look
back 20 years and say what do I want to
do with this which is you don't get that
you don't get that very often where it's
like you get to to look at a second
draft of this and go oh there were
things I did or he didn't even know
necessarily what books 2 3 4 5 and now
six were going to be
so we can now pull from all of that all
of that material to layer this
throughout and so I think it was
exciting for him to dive into this and
say what can I pull into Lightning Thief
for this season speaks to the value of
continuing a series there's always more
to discover and more to evolve along the
way another specific thing I wanted to
ask you guys about was the choice to
cast actors that are a similar age to
the characters can you maybe explain why
some Productions don't do that and why
you felt it was important to do that
here it's really easy to explain um they
can only shoot for half a day and so
everything gets really complicated um
it's also really easy to explain why we
felt like we had to um if I'm 12 years
old and I'm watching 19-year-olds have
the conversations I have when I'm 12
something's not right and I think in
order to start the story where it wanted
to be which was these kids who were just
starting the experience of becoming a
teenager and just emerging from the
experience of of being a child you got
to feel it and there's really no way to
cheat it and so you just embrace all of
the things that it comes with and you
hope you find great kids and we did so
it uh it ended up working out and you
need great Partners who will support
that because a lot of people first
question you get when you dive into a
project like this is like oh can they be
18 because then you can work on full
days and and that was really not a
factor here it was very clear from the
top Rick was very adamant about it we
were very adamant about it and and the
studio and and Disney supported it the
entire time but that adds days that adds
cost that adds just just complication
and it it just but it was always it was
always the Mantra that that's how this
has to be so glad you stuck your ground
on that matter big broad question going
into filming season 1 which scene did
you think would be most challenging to
pull off and then ultimately was that
indeed the most challenging or did a
different one Catch You by surprise I
think going into it the Nar sequence
feels pretty apparent that it's going to
come with a whole host of challenges to
it and in a way I think it makes it a
little easier cuz you know what you're
getting into and you go into it with all
of the resources kind of brought to bear
for it there are things that sneak up on
you I think as being a little bit more
complicated than they first appeared in
trying to figure out a way to make
Medusa someone who um both was connected
to her Canon mythologically and in the
book
um but felt new and different that was a
slightly tougher nut to crack um as a
design issue as much as a character
issue as much as a casting issue as much
as a voice issue um and so um that was
something that I I'm I'm pretty proud of
that we were able to kind of figure out
a way to make all of those things work
in the same package any other examples
you can give us for me and it's going to
take a few more episodes to get there
but is the underworld um the scope the
scale a 35t three-headed dog um there
was there's a lot to figure out and
every set piece had to be massive um and
how to achieve it and the design for it
Dan hen our production designer did such
a beautiful job um but it was really
really complicated and I'm pretty
excited about how it turned out all
right I saved my most dangerous question
for last I know when you go into season
one of a show you often have a series
roadmap well can you tease about that
series roadmap but then also given you
learn every step of the way is there
anything about that planned road map
that has changed based on what you
learned making season one the road map's
easy Rick wrote it so in a way that um
that most shows don't have you know
exactly where you're going um I think
the the nature of these books is such
that um are there things you learn from
book to book for sure but they're such
different movies um and every one of
these things um if we're fortunate
enough to to go about making them um is
going to bring
all of a whole a whole series of new
questions and problems and puzzles into
into the mix so um hopefully well we
should be so lucky to end up having to
solve those problems do I dare ask if
you want to add anything to that
one um I mean that's what's exciting
about the books is that that each one is
so different from the one that came
before so it's just these new challenges
you know our Our Hope as we get to to
dive into those and and figure it out
and that's what was season one was like
okay how do you do Mount Olympus how do
you do the underworld how do you do some
of these really complicated creatures um
and when you have the best team around
you um you you you figure it out and
that's what we're most proud
of